ei brought a brand-new battlefield one
map to Gamescom
it's called Saracen it's included in the
new in the name of the Czar expansion
and we've got a full match for you right
here be sure to subscribe to GameSpot to
keep up with all the battlefield one
gameplay especially since there are
still expansion packs on the way I
believe you can only get one tank per
per faction is that correct right each
team only gets one tank so it's gonna be
a critical part of each match and as you
can see here this is a very unique tank
this is not this is not a Russian tank
Russians were known for their armored
cars during World War one this is a mark
5 it's a British tank in 1919 they
started to support the Russian
Revolution one of the things I do want
to point out on this particular map is
the fact that there are only three flags
now this is actually not common in
battlefield so very very small map and a
lot of action I imagine if you haven't
around that view site that's right yes
and as we know and for those who don't
know conquest is all about capturing
those flags that's your objective you
need to go capture those flags and get
those points The Kills will also count
for you but this is this is what what
you're going for this is the bat the
tri-state battlefield one note and
actually just on screen now I think this
is one of the new weapons that's coming
with this expansion pack yes this is the
Perino and looks like we also pulled out
the obras but yeah this is a free no
it's it's also dressed up in the new
skin the fabergé yeah it looks really
good that one actually and that's a set
across all of the new weapons that are
coming right that's right yeah it's it's
something that we're showing off a
little bit and it's it's to kind of
honor one of the Russian designers and
now we have one of probably the best
shot Gunners out where was Jack frags
out there but now we switched over to
darkness here who is once again going to
be using that new LMG and you can see
him trying to get as much ammo out to
his teammates there to cap over onto the
sea flag now this is something that we
have seen in previous games where you
know that be sights so hard to take that
you do have people going in for the
flanks and now it's gonna be interesting
to see how the the light Guard actually
come back at this yeah cuz I should say
the the Red Army falling behind here a
little bit but the two
two flags on the outside a and C they're
sort of like the gimme flags right and a
little fight sort of focuses around that
being Centrepointe yeah taking the place
close to your headquarters gonna be the
simple task but good group teams are
gonna start flanking around and trying
to take those points the most
contentious point is going to be be in
the cathedral of light in the center of
the map you can see some of the the more
flatter areas around the Cathedral of
light here but obviously a lot of cover
as well there's some some rudimentary
trenches there there's some heavy cover
lots of like broken wood and barbed wire
as well so there's lots for sort of
infantry to hide in yeah absolutely you
did mention the rudimentary trenches and
that's something to note on the eastern
front they didn't spend a lot of time
digging those trenches like they did on
the Western Front during World War one
such showcased here so we've also seen a
lot of the basically destruction
buildings that are kind of torn down how
much extra destruction can the player
have as on this map oh that's a great
question actually not a whole lot
there's going to be some you'll see a
little bit of what we call micro
destruction but the hard cover that
we're seeing is stuff that we wanted to
keep in game to keep the game balanced
make sure that you stay safe when you're
weaving in and out to get to your
objectives now I think I'm right in
saying here that the the a capture point
is a heavily infantry focus right yes it
is it is within those ruins of the of
the former neighborhood and it's gonna
be hard for a tank to get those lines of
sight but as you can see there there's a
there's a sort of a large roadway
through the middle of it but if they try
to branch off down maybe one of the
smaller alleyways which they can get
down that but there's infantry
everywhere it's gonna be really tight
and you might find yourself with a mine
in your way see down here at the bottom
of the screen one of the Machine down is
using the old mark-5 tank that's buried
in the ground as cover there it's a
really good use of cover it's an
indestructible piece right there right
now though a massive wave coming in from
that be site to try and push those
players back into their alpha flag but
this is pretty interesting right now
because we do have that bottleneck that
you're talking about but it's kind of on
the reverse they can't really break out
into it that tank maybe needs to get a
little bit more aggressive try and push
on in there but they're just having one
heck of a time here yeah the red arm
you're trying to push in but as you
could see in a couple of shots back the
the white guard are sitting in that
first line of trenches is about seven
soldiers in there just sort of keeping
this tank from pushing forward you can
see with the explosives coming in on the
yeah the kind of keeping in their bake
has too many infantry around a tanky it
will take it down that's right
looks like we just entered into the
Cathedral of light gear and we're
hopping on the window yeah but here we
can actually see inside and this is
something I think we should talk about
because it's actually a beautiful
building inside that yeah a lot of work
was put into that building it's it's a
shame that most players are going to be
running around quite hectically during
them in there if you have a time to stop
and just look it's really beautiful here
we are with the this is the
double-barrel shotgun we should be able
to get a little bit of action with it
here that's right that one I'm right in
thinking that you can fire both shells
at once with this thing if you want to
yes that's like a double dose of pain
right there absolutely it is fantastic
we're taking out the cavalry cavalry men
as well but right now oh we have another
new gun right here on screen this is
from the medic class I believe that's
right so Fedorov ab2 Matt and this one
is really unique in that it allows you
to be able to choose your firing type so
you can go burst or you can go
single-shot and we are starting to see
right now the score kind of pulled a
very nice shot it's a nice takedown yeah
but we can see the white guard pulling
away just a little bit in terms of score
here and as you say they've they've held
the majority of fives two out of three
for most of the game so far and the red
are the Red Army tank wasn't really
pushing too much towards the the be
point the Cathedral and I think that's
going to be something they'll need to do
if they want to try and take it back
because the tank having the presence
it's going to allow infantry to move up
around the outside of it
and right now we can't see a pretty big
battle happening over here on to that
sea side of the map it looks like they
are gonna be able to defend it for now
but they are getting a lot of pressure
on that that particular points and for
now looks like they will be able to hold
it off a little bit of push coming in
onto the Cathedral but you can just see
how difficult it is especially without
any good tank which potentially could go
down here but the whole nice shotgun
there has that's gonna be Jack Bragg's
can he come out he does gets the night
beautiful job that was a nice tight down
that was good close quarters with the
shotgun couldn't quite finish him off
without the knife job done one thing to
note about this map is it is actually a
critical point in a critical place it's
been the port of the Volga River so
anyone who controlled this point also
got to control the the route of supplies
so this was something that the Red Army
really wanted to take and control while
they were trying to fight their way to
control Russia right now they're facing
a rather big push from the white guard
as you can see here we've got some tank
action going on but they seem to be
separated at the moment there's so much
infantry action going on in the middle
but they don't want to push too much and
then lose the tank part of a battle tank
is really trying to hold on here yeah
the Red Army really struggling to get
any point now almost gonna be it three
captain we all know that if you get
three captain conquests the game could
in fairly early so they really need to
rally back and get on to that point as
quickly as possible
I think they've solidified the a capture
point now looking at it again it doesn't
appear to be contested right now so
perhaps they sort of settled back down
again but they really do need to make a
push for that Cathedral if they want to
try and pull their way back in I think
that's the that's the key to this win
right here anyone who controls B is
going to have that that victory see here
doing some damage against that enemy
tank all the explosives going on this is
why the infantry can be so dangerous
especially when it's just one tank on
its own you know this is the only
vehicle that your that your team's gonna
have you really need to try and protect
it from enemy infantry
yeah it is really just a fantastic site
right they're looking at it from above
you do have some cavalry trying to come
in maybe do a little bit of harassment
there but this tank is literally just
IDI doesn't know what to do he's already
pushed all the way back to the out of
bounds own but we are gonna be seeing
him slowly but surely kind of inching
his way up he's about half health so he
does need to be careful by it you know
this is really interesting too because
we haven't really seen too much from the
other teams tanks so maybe they've kind
of just focused on purely just pushing
them in terms of infantry oh here we see
an actual battle going on at the
Cathedral right now you can see the flag
is being contested both sets of infantry
are in here trying to battle it out and
as much as it looks just like a building
on its own it is a really large building
this is a great shot here you can see
the full scope of the building now yeah
it's absolutely insane the size and
scope of this building not only that but
you do have some vertical gameplay with
it because one of the one of the
entrances where it's crumble that the
cyber has been hit by a shell of some
sort you can actually get up into sort
of the first level of buildings around
the top there yeah I actually think
that's gonna be one of the keys to
victory to for this point when you can
get to high ground you can control that
point one of the things I do want to
point out though is that the Red Army is
starting to come back they were capping
over there onto that Bravo point they
have about four minutes left so it is
possible for them to come back and try
and take this win here they just need to
hold on to these two flags but a massive
fight now happening for the center and
you can see right now the white guards
starting to win that back slowly but
surely as the new weapons are being used
to quite affect here and this is just
chaos right here in the middle of the
map just lets live you suspected when we
were building the map that this was
gonna be the most contentious area lots
of people pouring into the doors and
trying to get access to this point and
as you say like that you can see just
across from each other there's two sort
of entrance doors and there's one at the
rear and at the front you can almost
jump out from the top floor as well
there's lots of different ways that
infantry can get in and out of this
building so whatever team is in there
has got to be careful that the enemy
team doesn't try and come and take it
straight back at the same time though
the team in the center has to be careful
not to get too concentrated because if
you look there they were taking their
back flag so they don't make sure they
kind of spread out kind of get a little
bit even throughout the map and then
defend that way but you know right now
the the flank is going to be work
for I believe it was the Red Army trying
to go ahead and secure those two caps
yeah you can see here the yeah the Red
Army have got control of the a capture
point and I believe they're contesting
the C working on C and they're working
on it and we got a flame trooper right
here so how many kits do we have for the
elite class that we actually have three
elite classes on here right now so you
can get the flame trooper and that's
around the outskirts of this area here
the perimeter of the Cathedral you may
also find a central kit here we also
have a water-cooled
of LMG centric it that's that's a
something that will spawn on your
headquarters if you control all three
points okay so there's a third one
further away from the edge you look at
all the enemies here is going to roast
them nice and toasty picks up one picks
up a second one potentially here and he
just did a fantastic job of clearing out
those players we'll have plenty of
health as well and he's gonna re-engage
a fantastic job from here great use of
the flame trooper right here I'm
guessing this is what you guys exactly
thought would happen with the
flamethrower we'll put it near the
Cathedral where it's gonna be most
effective right right in these hallways
just a perfect use running train on
these guys but we got two minutes left
here on this particular map a little
over a hundred points down for the Red
Army right the white the white guard is
pulling away here they seem to have
dominated very much from the start and I
think perhaps the Red Army just suffered
a little bit from not being a little bit
more aggressive at the start trying to
contest the cathedral earlier on maybe
try and get a bit more of a foothold in
the match yep absolutely you can see
right now just so much chaos you have
the above action there from the second
level shooting on down so many players
just trying to scramble and get up there
as quickly as possible to clear that as
we're still following Jack here in the
flame sure for now we're gonna be
passing it on too thick as we will be
pushing on him once more hmm no it's not
gonna make it this is this is the
problem like because the the white guard
are sitting inside the Cathedral the Red
Army are having a horrible time trying
to actually get in yeah but it looks
like MIT got the tank up close it's just
taking a lot of fire damage here
he's doing damage to the tank by hitting
it with the flame that's about to sounds
like there's no way he's gonna take out
a tank with a flamethrower here and you
can see right now yeah just the infantry
trying to pour it from the sides but not
able to do so the tank is kind of
baffled as to what to do right here he
is getting a couple of kills but this is
not look at Civ craziness going down
we're down to the almost the last half a
minute here
yeah we're getting really close down to
the Y here the Red Army is still trying
to break in to the Cathedral that have
made a little bit of headway but they
are contesting the flag now but it may
be too little too late I think we might
be seeing yeah a little bit of that to
writing on the wall here absolutely but
you do have a little bit of life left
here and these squads they're gonna try
and do everything they possibly can it's
all for pride right here now can they
get this B side if they own it
oh my god yeah six seconds left to go we
are getting anything out here I think
there was a big hit I don't think they
quite got it and it looks like that was
it that was a victory for a white white
heart a white car took that one but that
was that was awesome what you looked at
Deidre ball that was really really good
fun and it just showcases like how
powerful infantry can be against
vehicles absolutely yeah this is just a
glimpse of what you get in the name of
the star we are super excited to see
what the